[Music]
well welcome back
everybody uh the adventure dominant
circus circus
is a great place to take the kids for
fun and they're open
with reduced capacity on all their rides
now
and our own hector mejia is riding a
brand new one this morning
it's called the nebula z it's 32 feet up
in the air
it scoops riders up and it spins them
around
and turns them around and hector mejia
is brave enough to get on it this
morning
now hector i have to ask you when you're
done riding this ride
let us know is it really fun is it scary
do you recommend it that is if you can
actually talk to us when you're done
riding the ride
tell us how it is sherry it's a little
bit of both
it's fun and scary when it's just
spinning up in the air
feels like i was spinning for the last
hour and i've been uh just
up here for the last few minutes waiting
for
our turn to uh talk to you guys about
this but joining us live we have tom
to explain you know where this ride came
from
and just how fast it spins it's pretty
fun
i'm almost speechless right now
[Laughter]
we go to an amusement show every year
and we saw this at the
as the center piece of the as the show
and we got excited about it and
explained to our owner mr ruffin how
this would be a perfect
mix of our ride rides and attractions
inside the park here
and i think we hit a home run with the
nebula z
tell us about the name it has a pretty
funky sounding name
nebula z so uh nebula
is a gas or a dust particle cloud
in in the universe and we thought that
this
is a perfect mix of a lot of different
features
up down round and round and and it's a
perfect
perfect name for a new ride inside the
theme park we're excited about it all
right tom let's see if i can pull this
off let's go ahead and turn this on
and see if i can still give a live
report
while the ride is spinning so i'm told
in terms of speeds the ride goes about
it spins about 14 times each minute
and uh it opened last month here we go
it's accelerating speed is increasing
i'm now looking down
so far it's fine but then it just
increases in speed and that's where the
scariness begins when you're just uh
kind of dropping down and you have that
gut feeling
and then you are going up again down and
you just have that theme park feeling on
a roller coaster
and i have to say i am not
a fan of roller coasters or
riots at the theme park so it took a lot
for me to get on this ride
and uh you can hear my voice just kind
of shaking because you feel a different
feeling when you're up here
especially when it's spinning but anyway
since it took a lot for me to get up
here i think everyone knows me either
uh maybe some lunch or some dinner
oh that you that you've earned with your
ride or that you've left with your right
okay well i think i lost my lunch
oh no i know oh no
i hope these things are waterproof
that was all for you we should also
point out that this was hector's idea
just for the record
you know reporters pitch their story
ideas and they have different things
this was as far as i know hector's idea
sherry so it wasn't like sort of conning
him into this
i think i'm getting sick just by having
the roller coaster
twisting his arm yeah yeah nate what do
you have behind you
this is one of the roller coasters they
had that's the poster yeah
yeah but it doesn't feel very good just
standing here
i'm getting motion sickness without
going anywhere wow
thank you daryl well that's it you know
guys
when you do the i was gonna say when you
do the roller coaster you know
you prepare yourself for that one big
dip but this ride the nebula z it looks
like you're doing
that that dip over and over again every
time you're going up and down
i don't think my stomach can take it
alex what do you reckon
nope no thank you uh i don't know if
this was hector's idea just oh my god
but hector is dedicated
so good job to hector sherry so
i think hector has earned a take one for
the team hector
a double dip of ice cream i think that
thing gets fair enough
plus some i think he's already done that
yeah starbucks for a year